hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from Frankfurt Germany it's
nine o'clock over here
don't know what time it is over there
and we have a big day today we're going
to be talking a little bit about special
relativity what in the world is that
that's special that's what a very
special anyways I'm going to include
some of the uh questions that people
made in another segment I'm going to do
a little review of space-time because
apparently a lot of people had questions
or comments to make uh about space-time
and of course we'll begin with our
Extinction segment and I guess the
question is you know what is the state
of the world
are we getting any closer to Extinction
or maybe deliberately or inadvertently
you know maybe postponing it with good
decisions by our uh politicians and
economists
which is it and I can't really tell you
myself
you know sometimes it feels like they're
trying to do their best
considering the tools they have you know
whatever's available to them uh create
more money you know try to hold on uh
keep inflation low uh raise uh uh labor
in other words uh employment uh
hopefully reduce taxes you know maybe
maybe that's what they're trying to do
that's these are the tools they can work
with
but the question is that on the other
hand you've got you know you got these
two worlds that they've now created the
Eastern world you know Russia and China
on the one hand
and the Western World Europe and the
United States primarily and the other
and unlike uh China yeah China has the
same population and or more population
than Europe and the United States
combined
and but China's a union whereas the
United States is a or the the American
Empire is a confederation
United States has to constantly send its
people out there to different countries
to say look we want you to do this for
us you know because those countries are
aligned with the United States but they
don't have a direct you know order from
Washington even though sometimes it
seems like that okay but uh China on the
other hand say Union you know uh unions
usually are stronger than confederations
anyways that's just a thought there
um let's see what the state of the world
is uh these are some Notions that you'll
see out there this week a hundred
trillion World economy we're getting to
the 100 trillion
of course a lot of that is inflation
devaluation you know but what do you see
there well you see China and the United
States and for China it says it's uh
probably going to catch up or pass or
pass the United States as the number one
economy in the world in about five years
that's what the projections are and
meanwhile they say on the other hand the
United States has been the number one
economy of the world since 1871.
so the reign of this new uh Rome
you know this new Roman Empire uh seems
like it's coming to an end
the numbers show that and again a lot of
these projections are just mathematical
projections
they don't have to do necessarily with
physics they have to do with math you
know they just say what was the average
growth in the last few years well they
project that and they say and that's
what we think is going to happen but
sometimes you can't you know physics is
a little different than math in that
sense right uh realities out there don't
necessarily match what these economists
you know they're doing their blackboards
that's what I'm saying anyways you can
see Europe uh has fallen behind compared
to what it was last century it was a
Powerhouse now it's falling behind the
United States and China
and so
that's something to keep in mind there
are some changes going on in the world
and the question is whether China will
surpass the United States the next five
years or not and this is what the trend
looks like you can see that Europe and
Japan are falling behind their curve is
not so pronounced and China on the other
hand is uh growing faster than the US in
fact twice as fast as the United States
and again they expect it to pass the
United States in the next five years
okay these are the projections again a
lot of this just math not physics it
doesn't necessarily reflect what's
happening on the ground or what will
happen on the ground next few years
these are just projections
we cannot predict the future even though
our science critic believes otherwise
okay and says uh China will become the
global economy's biggest growth driver
in the next five years doubling the U.S
contribution IMF South the international
monetary fund China will contribute 22.6
percent of total World growth while the
U.S will only contribute 11.3
that's about half
exactly half if you follow those numbers
uh half of global growth would be
concentrated in China the U.S India and
Indonesia these are very populist
countries that's why they put them up
there China will become the biggest
driver of global growth over the next
five years and will contribute double
what the U.S ads according to the IMF
okay
and uh yeah you can see that the numbers
show that
um it's essentially China is going to
pass the United States whether that will
happen or not that's a separate issue
and that's economics and remember uh
economics does translate into military
power as well and that's another thing
to look out for very important Point by
the way okay
okay so because of that the United
States you know is a little worried
about that Trend and it's acting now so
that maybe in five years
what the IMF projects doesn't happen
that's maybe the hope the prayer right
and it's putting the pressure on
countries to cut their relations with
China
as part of that deal to see if they can
slow China's growth down at the same
time attempting to deprive China of any
thing that can help its uh military okay
that's those are the the ideas behind
the rulers in the United States and here
we have in a case uh Italy thinks it's
close China ties as U.S backs stronger
break and you can see there at the
bottom you know they want to pull Milani
who is the prime minister of Italy
um she wants to pull out of this
so-called um uh belt and Road initiative
and I'll cover that in a second here but
you can see the trends there
um China is selling more to Europe than
what it's buying and the deficit is
growing and so that
um you know they're they're trying to
see if they can overturn that or at
least uh you know somehow prevented from
being so
um so exponential as it looks there okay
um what is the this uh Road and Belton
Road Road in Belton or Belton Road
initiative Belton Road I think it is and
here it is uh it says the Belton Road
initiative is a global infrastructure
development strategy adopted by the
Chinese government in 2013 to invest in
more than 150 countries and
international organizations
and it's considered the center piece of
XI Ying Ping's foreign policy and it's
been compared to America's uh Marshall
Plan remember after World War II the
Marshall Plan was used to uh
re-construct Europe okay
um there's a lot of countries 151
countries that have signed up
and you can see there at the bottom what
does it cover initiative infrastructure
Investments include ports skyscrapers
railroads roads Bridges airports AMS
coal-fired Power Station railroad
tunnels so they've got a lot of
um uh you know infrastructure that
they're contributing to and what is
interesting is that you know it's
they've incorporated into the
constitution of China
so it's part of their constitution okay
so that's something to think about it's
something very serious as far as they're
concerned and this is what the map looks
like of this uh Belton Road okay and
again what is interesting there doesn't
seem to include uh the English-speaking
world too much you know especially the
United States and Canada they're not
there okay
um and I'm wondering how much it
includes uh you know Great Britain and
uh Australia and again I don't think uh
or New Zealand you know none of the
English-speaking countries are really
into this very much maybe they signed up
for one or two things there but they're
probably going to pull out just like
Italy is trying to do now okay so you
know again this is something that the
United States is not very fond of
because it only helps the Chinese
economy
it makes them look good also in the
United States plays no part in it and I
guess the United States is not very
happy with that okay
so you know again you got to look at
these things because these are the you
could say mega Trends yeah what's going
on out there
okay and uh similar matter we had here
uh Lula and he goes to uh Spain uh
Portugal he went also to Spain I think
and um and he was not greeted very
nicely by ukrainians over there you know
they said that uh his comments are not
well received and he was saying that uh
you know again he thinks that there
should be peace in Ukraine and that both
sides are guilty so to speak they put
him on he put him on equal footing and
they didn't like that they said no no
why on equal footing you know Russia has
invaded another country that's the way
they look at it in the west uh other
people look at it differently and one
thing I can share with you is the
following you know and that's uh you
know what is Brazil Brazil's uh biggest
country in South America that's what it
looks like uh map in the Americas uh
what is called Latin America okay and
North America only has Mexico anything
between Mexico and that uh Southern
continent we call South America is
um
Central America you know then you have
Cuba and other islands in the region
they're known as you know the Caribbean
Americas or whatever and then you have
South America which is the Big Green
part there
but uh there's uh maybe that's the uh
not a good way of separating all these
countries so let's uh look at a
different way of dividing this up okay
and there you can see Spanish speaking
countries versus Portuguese which is
essentially in Brazil that's it
and uh then you have some other
countries that speak French and English
there you know Belize uh they
have different languages Dutch French
and English but uh the main language
spoken in the in southern uh America
Indy you could call Latin America is uh
Spanish you got maybe 370 million people
speak Spanish there now I found on the
internet that it's about 200 and 200 212
for Spanish speaker and 206 I think it
was for the Portuguese I don't know
where they got those numbers you know
everybody speaks Spanish from Mexico to
Argentina and Chile
you know we understand each other in
every one of those countries no problem
uh they have some local words sometimes
you don't understand but in general you
know he can speak with anybody from
Mexico to Chile no problem uh Brazil
that's a different story they speak
Portuguese and anyone who knows Spanish
pretty much understands Portuguese if
they speak slowly enough but it's a
different language right more or less
but one thing they all have in common
and related to Ukraine is that uh you
know none of these countries red and
blue
uh fear Russia or China
they fear someone else and it's known as
the United States that's the one that
they fear about you know uh big stick
policy uh Monroe Doctrine any of those
ring a bell you know that's what they're
worried about uh the on the one hand
they can't live without the north uh
with the United States Empire and they
can't they would love to live without it
so they're in this catch uh 23 situation
you know
um can't live without them can't live
with them and uh but they have nothing
to fear from China or Russia so when a
guy like uh Lula president of Brazil
goes out there you know he's got this uh
more even uh version of what's going on
in Ukraine and he doesn't see the United
Russia as being the only aggressor they
say that in some instances but they
reach agreements with Russia as well on
economic stuff and they're not just
going to follow you know what the United
States dictates they're going to follow
their own uh interests and the same goes
for other countries in the Americas so
when China comes over and offers money
they say yeah I'll allow myself to be
bribed okay so you gotta look at that
you know the way they they're seeing all
this okay final note
um here we have something that's going
on teams out it comes out of the
telegraph says the nuclear family is
dead so it's not only population but the
nuclear family you know Mom Pop and a
couple kids
and it says and our politicians are to
blame
well I don't disagree that the nuclear
family is dead but I don't think it's
got anything to do with the politicians
and the article essentially says that
they're not giving any incentives for
people to have children
and I'm not sure that's going to change
anything okay it says fertility rates
have been halved over the past seven
decades a third of adults adults have
never been married lots of people are
not even getting married today so the
old-fashioned tradition of getting
married you know that's dying uh in fact
uh like I like to say a lot of people
who are getting married today
disproportionately uh disproportionate
amount of people are homosexuals because
they just want to prove that they have
the right whereas those who have the
right say well you know I'm not going to
make use of my right like a lot of
people don't make use of their right to
vote you know they say I'm not going to
vote and so it was uh like an irrelevant
right that they have to get married or
to vote and in in the case of marriage
you know if you don't get married you
don't have long-term relations
even if you do get married you get
divorced three months later you know
again that's not a long-term relation
you don't have kids that is not a
long-term relation and this speaks
volumes of what's going on today you
know we're not having children partly
because you know like I said we moved to
the cities from the country we become
urbanites and urban people don't have
children that's why I don't think
politicians have much to do with that
issue
uh but then on the other hand uh you've
got this situation where people are not
getting married which is part of the new
culture uh service economy
bachelors or homosexuality or whatever
non-producing people
okay so no marriage no kids
that's where we stand
okay let me move on to this issue of
space-time which we covered the other
day there were some issues there what I
did was I went in there and looked at a
um a channel YouTube channel it's got uh
I think the name is history of the
universe they've got over 500 half a
million uh uh
subscribers
and what do they talk about well they
talk about nonsense uh that's what I
found out but I thought maybe just maybe
you know space time is something
different and no the whatever they said
about space-time is absolute uh I'll be
kind poppycock okay that's what it is
and this is what the channel looks like
says what actually your space and time
do they even exist
okay I think those are valid questions
to answer
and let's see how they uh answered them
uh this is their what their train of
thought was uh they put on John Wheeler
to comment that John Wheeler made he was
a John Archibald Mueller he was a um
mathematical physicist mathematician
actually uh the math is a language they
do a lot of math a lot of equations and
then they reach all irrational
conclusions including this nonsense
about space-time and so you know they
looked at space and they looked at time
do they exist and this is what wheeler
had to say about spaces what is space
behind it all is surely an idea so
simple so beautiful listen to this that
when we grasp it in a decade in a
century or a millennium we will all say
to each other how could it have been
otherwise how could have how could we
have been so stupid
totally agree
the only thing important that John
Mueller said in his life everything else
was nonsense okay okay so uh they go in
there and they go from Aristotle to uh
Newton and leibniz and it says uh that
you know in 2000 years it took them to
come up with a Notions of space and time
that we have today okay so they go in
there and they said uh you know
Aristotle said you know that there's no
such thing as an empty void okay
everything in other words there is no
such thing as space meaning nothing even
that is something that's essentially
what Aristotle said and that grew over
the years as by the 17th century the
processes of the universal being
codified into physical laws but it
continues as the understanding of these
physical laws was evolving from myths
and stories to what the language of
mathematics
we need to have mathematics to tell us
what spaces
what do we need math to tell us what
space is if it's a thing if it's a
concept again you know I don't think we
need math at all but this is what how
they start their presentation so they're
all already off on a tangent on uh you
know in the middle of the jungle
lost
uh Newton said space and time exists in
a university void of matter he thought
that space and time were out there even
if matter was removed from the universe
and London says no without matter there
is no space of time there would be it
would have no meaning okay
but uh they also said that unlike space
time has a Direction
oh uh please point to it
yeah uh is it that way or is it that way
I don't know what direction time flows
for me and right now it's flowing
forward I don't know about you maybe
it's flowing in the opposite direction
so I don't know what direction uh time
is Flowing okay
okay uh so they continued in there see
if they can zero in on what space and
time are says the explosion of the
universe is the expansion of space
expansion of space so they're saying
they're treating space as a balloon more
or less right they're saying it's
something that's expanding okay
expanding from 13.8 billion years since
the Big Bang
but simple there are uh there there was
less space yesterday
and there will be more space tomorrow
so not only uh are they confirming that
it's a physical object here you have
something that's expanding and there's
there was more of this in the future and
less of it in the past
so I guess they're talking about a thing
you know it's like saying you have more
money or less money or that you have uh
I don't know more uh sand
uh bigger house you know they're talking
about a thing they're talking about
physicality here right
uh galaxies are not moving through space
uh-huh
space simply gets between them so here
you have space growing pushing the
galaxies apart that's what they're
saying okay
the universe is becoming less dense in
other words the matter apparently
Remains the Same but it's space that's
pushing all the matter apart I guess
including the atoms within you but they
address that you are not you are and and
not slowly drifting apart gravity holds
you together
so thanks to gravity otherwise we'd blow
up like the guy on the bottom there okay
but this gravity uh is manifestation of
the curvature of space
uh they lost me I mean if the atoms are
being held together what's that got to
do with curved space
I mean they're talking about the
uh being held together within you that's
why you don't blow up and then they talk
about curved space
uh how do you reconcile that what's you
know I guess they're saying that each
atom has its own curved little space and
it's so curve that it's pulled to the
other because of the little curved space
my God
these people have uh no no idea
whatsoever
okay here's another famous so-called
physicist mathematical physicist died
recently uh his name is Weinberg okay
Stephen Weinberg he was a Nobel Prize
winner how is it possible for space
which is utterly empty to expand yeah
good question how can nothing expand
love it that's that's the question you
got to answer the answer is Pace does
not expand
they just said space expands now they
say space does not expand okay and then
sends relativity space time is truly
nothing
they say this okay I'm just quoting now
these are statements taken out of that
video okay relativity tells us that
space is nothing and has no property
okay space space time they're nothing
but they're expanding space is expanding
and there's more of it
what the hell are they talking about I
mean it either is a physical object when
you talk about expanding like you see
there you're talking about a physical
object something is pushing
you know the uh galaxies apart and you
might say well it's not pushing space is
growing yeah but what would the uh
galaxies go apart unless the water you
know is pushing them on the little boats
apart there's more water so it pushes
the boats apart so space is treated like
a physical object that is pushing on the
galaxies okay so I don't know how you're
going to avoid the notion that they're
presenting here that space is something
and then he says oh no by the way space
is nothing
so they live with these contradictions
they don't even realize it they just
keep going as if nothing
okay so they move into the block
Universe okay famous in relativity all
past presence and future are already
written
okay we're cartoons in a cartoon uh you
know just uh whatever the uh cartoonist
Drew in there whatever the uh script was
whatever the plot was you have to follow
it because you know Bugs Bunny cannot
act outside the script that the writer
the author you know put in there for you
and the uh artist you know they make
them do certain things he's got to do
them because you can't say I'm not going
to do that
I can't imagine you know Bugs Bunny is
doing that right the entire history of
all things is already out there
everything has already happened you're
walking on footsteps okay this notion is
known as the block universe as we Trace
out our world line we follow our
predefined path Concepts dear to us such
as free will or lost
you have no free will okay there it is
proof evidence okay you have no free
will because as you can see that uh
Fallen glass uh no beer in there uh but
uh that Fallen glass that is space-time
it's already there and we're somewhere
you know they always point us at put us
at the end of that you know the rim of
the glass that's not really true uh what
they're trying to tell you is that space
time already exists
you know space and time time in Memorial
to infinity or to the Big Crunch
whatever it's already there all we can
do is just walk on our footsteps because
the story of the universe has already
been written
interesting if you believe in this
nonsense okay and yeah that's more or
less also what Saint Augustine said so
they haven't invented anything these
relativists they just paired it what
Augustine said you know says God is
outside of space-time of the universe
and he's a spirit so he can't move
because Spirits don't move
Spirits are Concepts Concepts don't move
okay and he created the universe and
he's outside of time because time is
inside the universe
and God knows what's going to happen
because it's already happened you can
see it all there right in front of him
Brian Green's loaf of bread that I
talked about the other day okay
okay
where does the sleeve says we know that
our universe didn't stretch infinitely
into the past it had a beginning from
our observations we know that the
Universe was born almost 14 billion
years ago okay so they know they know
this it's been proven certified
can't all you got to do is memorize it
from now on we don't know the process
that brought it into being ah but that
was the important part but it was born
with both space and time just where and
how space and time came to be in the
universe remains a mystery oh no kidding
the important stuff they they did the
one they had to answer they can't answer
there are other mysteries about the
birth of the universe that we don't
understand there clearly must have been
something special about our universe's
birth but what this was we still don't
know it's just a bunch of don't knows
and I don't know and who knows and we
now under We Now understand how
Einstein's space-time works but we still
don't know what it is
okay so uh we got a lot of
contradictions here because they say
space time is a thing it's expanding
okay there's more of it every day
then the other guy says oh by the way
space time and space right are nothing
okay everybody explain what it is in the
alternative and these people say oh by
the way we don't know anything about
with space time is we don't know what
space is we don't know what time is
but we know it all
okay great you know they they know
there's been an origin to space-time
they don't know how it came to be they
have no idea they cannot explain that of
course they can't and then they say uh
by the way we we don't know how it came
to be or where it's going or what it is
but they know everything about it great
and here it is at the smallest possible
scale at the tiny Planck scale
space-time is chunky
chunky that means it's a thing
right talking about a thing because he
says it's chunky I mean you're not going
to say that love is chunky
unless you're a lousy poet right mesh
together into a network
I think very straightforward they're
talking about a thing okay space and
time become granular
little seeds or whatever you know the
event as uh Hawking defined it is a
point in space-time that's an event and
these people are saying that little
point that little dot is granular okay
because they're trying to emerge you
know quantum mechanics with general
relativity right
because of the fundamental length and
fundamental time plank scale pixels that
we set that set the smallest resolution
of the universe okay again they're
talking about these little dots that
make up space time that's what they're
talking about
this would mean that at the smallest
scale space and time would be nothing
more than grains of sand on a beach you
see it at the bottom that's what space
time looks like rains of sand on the
beach okay
what are these Quantum grains made of
again we are left disappointed as they
just are
so uh they don't know nothing that's
what it is they know nothing absolutely
not you always end up with this wall of
these Hell by the way we don't
understand it we don't we don't know
what it is but we've proven it
okay our measurements right we've proven
it okay so it says what is space and
time are not really there now they're
talking about existence right perhaps
space and time do not exist at all
oh my God so space is something
right because it's growing it's becoming
bigger every day there's more of it
right then space time is nothing
then they say they don't know what it is
and now they're wondering if it exists
at all
this is all the same video okay that's
what I'm saying it's so much pop speak
up cannot be condensed into a movie but
they did it they they managed what is
space and time or actually emergent
phenomena something we experience only
as what macroscopic beings so perhaps
there is no space between the grains of
reality no time between one grain and
another to these grains these Concepts
make no sense
laughs well yeah I had never talked to
one of these brains to find out if it
makes sense or not but maybe one of
these grains one day will tell me you
know okay for us much larger than the
scale of these grains there is the
concept of space ultimately space and
time maybe don't exist
are these people for real
I mean it took they made this uh video
it took one hour
and I had to spend through this whole
thing just to see it all to see you know
what came out of it all in this this is
what they came out with uh okay and I
guess uh this is the punch line here yes
space and time are far more strange than
they first appear are we any closer to
really understanding space times true
nature of course nature is not bound to
reveal its Secrets no matter how hard
scientists work they may never reveal
the fundamental truth we must face the
fact that some Mysteries might remain
forever Mysteries just what space and
time actually are could forever be
beyond our grass
and I spent one hour watching this
nonsense
so uh no uh all I can tell you is uh
they just chased their tails around they
have no idea what they're talking about
anymore uh is based on a physical object
uh they treated as such that they tell
you that it's nothing then they tell you
that uh perhaps it doesn't exist
and finally they say we don't even know
what it is but uh and we'll probably
never will
great love the show
it's got 500 000 uh hits or whatever
unbelievable
okay and so we had some questions since
last time and these are some of the
people who
know everything about space-time so they
came and told us for fortunately we have
all these scientists who came over to
tell us what space and time and space
time are okay here it is the first one
says scientists don't know what space
and time are never have and possibly
never will what we mean by space and
time hopefully shed light on the subject
in the future science is an attempt to
explain the natural world yeah since we
will always have an incomplete
understanding of the universe
it should not be expected that the
models generated by scientists will be
directly physical
oh there you have space and time well
what what's what is it that you don't
understand I mean space is one axis time
is the other axis and they took this
Cartesian coordinate system which is a
little weird because space includes
three dimensions there okay and then
they bend it downwards
and they say that's the reason the Earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system
you've probably seen the little ball you
know the Earth rolling around this
depression and that's their explanation
for why the planets don't fly out of the
solar system
so I don't understand what this file
doesn't understand we know exactly what
space and time are
you know this is not rocket scientists
uh stuff you know what it is is they've
taken time and they've taken space and
they converted it into physical objects
and even worse they took space and they
turned it into one coordinate right and
took time to put a replace height with
it and put it as the other coordinate
and that's how it is it's just a way of
locating points in space-time meaning
events meaning what all those grains of
sand that we just talked about
granular
so I don't know what uh what these
people don't understand it's very clear
we know exactly what space time is it's
known as nonsense it's poppycock that's
what it is okay here's another file says
uh Spaceman uh I think it's the same
power space might be something again to
air
okay maybe you might argue that well I
can feel air flowing against me but I
could respond by saying that I can tell
when I'm accelerated uh yeah maybe when
he injects himself
the sense of the acceleration could be
the feeling of our change in reference
frame in space time okay so he's saying
that uh just because he changes his
reference frame with respect to what to
something he calls space-time he's using
that he he drove a stake in the ground
that he calls space-time and from there
he says I can sense uh whether I'm
accelerating or not therefore I don't
think that it is true that space cannot
be regarded as an object see so he
thinks space is a thing yeah an object
that cannot be detected by human senses
is still an object yeah we don't dispute
that in fact we argue that here all the
time that uh you don't need to see or
touch
an object for it to be an object an
object is that which has shape what you
need to tell me what is the shape of
space-time and then we'll know if space
time is an object or not that's the
definition if you don't like the
definition and we got to go step back
and find out what an object is what a
thing is and for that you need to Define
what the word thing but the word
something with the word object is these
are all synonyms
so begin by defining what an object is
then we'll know what you're talking
about and yes you don't need to see or
touch an object for for it to be an
object that's not the definition of
object an object is that which has shape
it has shape before any human ever saw
or touched
okay
um
another fellow says the following says
where I think the same one says time we
need two frames of reference like you
said but where do these come from
obviously one comes from the present but
then where do the other come from does
the other come from uh the simple answer
seems to be kind of memory
some kind of memory okay yeah memory
okay but then how do you know that that
memory was not falsified
are these people for real what planet do
these people come from
it's got nothing to do with falsifying
or or or any of that nature we need to
define the word time
and we're still working on the word time
here and the guy jumps over and says
well what if the uh memory is falsified
that's the second step first we need to
find out if the word memory fits into
the definition of the word time before
we can do anything with the word time so
far we have not defined time we're not
finished with the word time
and he's already jumped he said well
what if the time what if the memory is
falsified
you know it's it's just unbelievable you
know what these people have uh the the
nonsense that goes through their brains
okay here's another phone he says the
following he says uh if space void is
nothing then the world is a plenum with
no separation
unless there is an entity whose sole
purpose is to separate things
so he's saying that is space that keeps
things apart Adams apart
so it's a thing because if space wasn't
there I guess the same thought that some
of these Greeks had uh you know space
wasn't there to push things apart they
would be together
so he thinks space is a thing because it
keeps things apart never occurred to him
that uh atoms are separated by you know
the electromagnetic ropes okay and that
has nothing to do with space space is
nothing meaning that which has no shame
we don't need space uh as a things space
is a concept it's the same thing as a
concept nothing
which is an antonym of something
something that which has shape space
which doesn't have shape very simple
well says space-time is real testable
and falsifiable relativity is real
testable or falsifiable
uh sorry in science we don't falsify
anything so I mean you know we can't
take you seriously yeah we don't falsify
the dollar bills uh IDs I used to do
that but I don't think
I don't do that any longer
okay uh another file says you can derive
the fact of space-time directly from the
invariance of the speed of light space
and time coordinates are intertwined
whoa it got tangled I guess right and
space coordinates changed the time
coordinates change
yeah they have all the I guess it's how
much beer these guys drink I don't know
what does this have to do with
space-time being a thing is space-time a
thing or not is it a physical object or
not
and all you have to do to prove that
space time is an object is draw it
illustrate it tell us what it looks like
and you say well you can't even imagine
it like uh Hawking Stephen Hawking said
um yeah then if you cannot even imagine
it then you don't know what you're
talking about
and you can't call it an object until
you do
and say well I can't because it's four
dimensional how much did you drink last
night bartender I went what he had you
know I mean they just come up with
idiocy that is math that has nothing to
do with physics physics right there out
there in the world in front of you but
these people have their minds going
beyond the universe and say ah but I'm
like God I'm outside the universe and I
find out that 3D is too little for me I
need 4D at least or five or what is it
String Theory up to 2060
yeah
proportional to the number of whiskeys
you drink I guess okay another fellow
says Albert Einstein helped develop the
idea of space-time as part of his theory
of relativity many years after its
proposal Einstein's theory of relativity
was proven
thanks to NASA's gravity probe okay
which demonstrated that space and time
were indeed linked
how can they prove that space and time
are linked physically linked I guess
because that's what gravity Pro B was
all about uh how did you prove that
space and time are linked if space and
time are not physical objects neither
one is a physical object certainly I
hope you can understand that time is not
a physical object but some people might
think that time is because they talk
about warping time right but yeah or
spending time or whatever
um but you know if space and time are
not physical things how can you link
them physically which is what you know
these people are talking about here
according to Einstein's general theory
about his space and time are tied
together
again uh they talk about the time being
a physical entity they're tying to
seconds with the meters I guess I don't
know maybe tying them into a knot and
space and time can bend and curve
how do you bend and curb time uh what do
you do you take the seconds and bend
them the hours the the years I don't
know I'm wondering but despite all the
things that space-time enables us to
predict and know it isn't real in the
same way that an atom is real
so in what sense is it real if it's not
like an atom
okay there's nothing you can do to
detect space-time directly
okay uh yeah because uh it's very hard
to detect Concepts like you know what
are you using uh a fork a spoon a
10-foot pole you know to to detect it
are you trying to touch it see it what
are you trying to do
okay if our consists it continues that
existence is applied to physical objects
requires measurements absolutely not we
don't need to do any kind of measurement
to talk about existence but again if if
that's the case then he contradicts
himself because on the one hand he says
that space them time exists but there's
no way to detect it through what uh
through measurement or anything like
that you can't touch it he can't measure
it I mean what is he going to do weigh
it and so if you can't detect it what's
uh he's saying on the one hand that it
exists on the other one he says it
doesn't exist does SpaceTime exist what
do you mean by exist in what way does it
exist he says it doesn't exist like an
atom exists whatever that means
okay don't give me an example if you
find the words Define exist and we'll
know what exists means how how it fits
into your def in your uh analysis there
right
and um
he says also the following he says uh we
are 40 beings our perception is what
needs to change
okay so there we have these four DBS and
no wonder he had these weird uh ideas
because he's a 4D being I guess
some kind of uh Tesseract uh being
coming from Mars I don't know
so yeah uh he says the perception needs
to change okay great I don't know what
we learned from all these people we
learned that they know nothing but was
it the Know Nothing party I talked about
the other day that's what they are
they're on the know nothing because
eventually they all tell you that oh by
the way we don't know anything
they've proven everything you know they
they want to teach you they they say
that you're wrong and then they say oh
by the way we don't know nothing
okay okay fella also kick start the uh
special relativity uh segment so we want
to find out what special relativity is
and uh this all comes along he says the
following he says that time dilation
right has been proven he says breaking
news just in he shouts it right that's
what happens with all these people hey I
rediscovers Einstein's time dilation
okay uh how an AI uh artificial
intelligence right got a little robot
there that rediscovers Einstein's time
dilation
okay I'm not sure uh what how an AI can
do that especially when AIS are actually
programmed but let's see where this uh
leads uh what is special relatively well
special relativity has
three essential theories built into it
one is that mass increases at a given
speed when it speeds up right uh rulers
you know uh lengths of rulers right they
contract when an object speeds up and
time dilates okay so they have these
three versions and here I've Illustrated
them for you okay a ruler contracts in
the direction of travel right uh mass
increases and I guess uh like a
ballooner you just inflate it or are
there more atoms I don't know and in
time dilates okay somehow the clocks
become uh wobbly you know okay these are
things that uh special relativity has
and therefore you can see that it's all
going to be a bunch of nonsense what
they're going to be proposing okay so
this is not for you to take seriously
this theory of special relativity okay
uh where did we get all this stuff well
we have a little summary here from uh
one of our primary physics sites physics
world right so it's linked contraction
the short story okay the idea of length
contraction was postulated by the iris
theoretical physicist George Fitzgerald
in 1889 and by the Dutch theorist
Hendrick Lawrence in 1892 also known as
Lawrence Fitzgerald contractor just
Lawrence contraction they forgot about
Fitzgerald right it was invoked to
account for the negative outcome of
Albert Michelson and Edward Morley's
memorable experiment in of 1887. the two
Americans had famously tried ahead and
failed to detect The Ether a
hypothetical stationary medium That was
supposed to carry electromagnetic waves
much as a surface of water carries water
waves right Keen to rescue the
hypothesis of a stationary ether
Lawrence and uh Fitzgerald's solution to
Michaelson and Morley's null result was
to suggest that objects traveling at a
substantial fraction of the speed of
light will when viewed by another
Observer meaning subjective right appear
shortened in the direction of their
travel based on a calculation by Oliver
heavicide of how the magnetic Vector
potential and Maxwell's equation
transformed between reference frames
okay so what does this history look like
let's go slowly Point by Point what
happened was that we had first these two
fellows
Michaelson and Morty and They carried
out a series of experiments the last one
was in 1887 up to that point I think
they had a couple more after that but
the main one where they published their
main result was 1887 okay think about
that 1887 uh Einstein was from 19 1879.
he was eight years old okay keep this in
mind okay Einstein was only eight years
old did he discover any of the stuff
that you were going to look at in a
minute I doubt it okay not at the age of
eight okay so here it is uh this is uh
Albert Michelson and morning uh and what
they did they uh said look you know if
you put some kind of sensitive device uh
when the earth is on one side of the Sun
and when it's on the other they should
be going in opposite direction to The
Ether win okay and so they carried out
this experiment in which they sent
um uh beams of light okay and you can
see there on the right what happened uh
they showed that uh what should have
happened and what what did not happen
and essentially uh they came up and they
said Look by the way you know we we
conclude that there is no ether they
thought there was an ether a bunch of
particles as I call them out there in
space that would slow down light and
that did not happen light had the same
speed in any direction they could not
detect any difference and because of
that they got rid of The Ether and a lot
of people didn't like that because
everybody in up to the up to that time
had been nurtured
in high school in college that there was
this ether out there so everybody just
took it for granted yeah there is an
ether we've had to eat there all the
days in every uh year since the days of
the Greeks so you know it was like
you're not going to take that away from
me now are you I mean Newton said
there's either Huggins said it's ether
even Descartes and Galileo all of them
said there's ether now you're telling us
that there is no ether
so uh Michelson and Morley's experiment
was um in that sense you know an
eye-opener people started complaining
uh about the fact that something must be
wrong maybe the measurement is wrong but
if the measurement is right
then uh perhaps there's something else
that we don't understand
and that's when some of these people
came up with alternative ideas and
um the first guy to attack that to some
degree okay was Oliver heavy side but he
did not really attack the Michelson
morning experiment what he did he went
in there and he was talking about
charges uh that move and he figured out
something that they when they move in
the direction in which they're traveling
you know when they move in that
direction the the he said that there's
something going on with them flattening
out the charge is flattened out so he he
puts this uh this
um
paper and what I like about this paper
uh yeah he says the following he says
all disturbances being propagated
through the dielectric ether at the
speed of light when therefore a charge
is in motion through the median the
discussion of the effects produced
naturally involves the consideration of
three cases those in which the speed U
of the charges less than or equal to or
greater than V that of light so you can
see there I've circled uh in his
equation 1 minus U which is the velocity
of the charge over V squared which is
the velocity of light and the reason I
put that in there that's the first time
I saw this relation
okay and uh what I'm saying is that's
what um Lawrence is later on going to
incorporate into the so-called Lawrence
factor which then in the end Einstein
takes credit for all of it okay but you
can see this is coming in out in 1888 at
the end of 1888 beginning of 1889 that's
when he published a series of five
papers and uh this was from uh the third
or fourth we were still in 1888 at the
end of 1888 November December and you
can see that uh that relation there I
think is probably the first guy to put
that in there okay and that's going to
be very important keep that one in mind
because you're going to see now what's
going to happen the next fellow to take
that information okay and use it to say
well we can explain maybe what happened
with Michaelson Morty with that
experiment maybe maybe something is
flattened out maybe light is being
flattened out okay and so this is the
article put out by Fitzgerald it wasn't
really an article he just wrote a letter
to Science magazine in those days and he
says the father he says the important
part right says the length of the
material bodies changes according as
they are moving through the ether or
across it okay so he was saying that
something is happening to the length of
the material body itself
okay okay so um so we already have the
notion that something's happening to the
objects the objects are getting
flattened out in the direction of travel
the first guy to notice that or to
suggest that was Heavy side now comes uh
one year later in that that same year
really because the fifth paper published
by heavy side was at the beginning of 89
same year uh Einstein is only 10 years
old okay uh same year
um Fitzgerald just writes this note he
became famous for that note alone just
that little letter that I wrote but uh
first guy to take credit for stuff that
he didn't do is Lorenz he goes in there
and he uses this Factor called the
Lorenz factor and there you see the
factor at the bottom right one minus
what V squared meaning the velocity of
the object over c squared which is the
velocity of light so he takes that
Vector he gets the square root of it one
over that and he's going to use that
factor to calculate length contraction
right mass and time eventually okay and
this was the work of different
mathematicians in those days but
Hendrick takes the credit these were the
Lorenz Factor which again I think really
the the fellow who zeroed in on that
first was Heavy side okay and again
um Lawrence publishes that in 1892
Einstein is what 13 years old now
okay I I don't think he under he knew
about any other stuff at the time okay
and uh what happens Heine comes in at in
1905 several years later he's 26 years
old ANS when he gets the credit for uh
relativity he writes a paper on that
1905 his first uh
I think it was his first or third paper
I can't remember now anyways he
publishes that and he's going to get the
credit for special relativity which is
disputed by pancare uh french guy also
he said hey you know I I did all this
work on special relativity this guy gets
the credit okay so they have that uh
situation there and again um Einstein
said there was an ether and they were
fighting over the nature of The Ether
that Einstein proposed versus the one
that uh Lawrence and uh heavyside and
all these other people proposed uh these
other people were proposing a static uh
ether so it was standing still and
everything was moving through this
sandbox that was the way they saw it and
Einstein saw it more as a dynamic easier
okay so petty stuff there is no ether so
it doesn't matter one way or the other
they were all wrong okay but those are
some of the differences between them
okay let's look at this uh first the
mass increase okay they're saying that
if an object travels close to the speed
of light because the Lawrence Factor
there that one minus uh V over C both
squared right that's factor is going to
tell them that the more you approach the
velocity of light
uh the more you're going to be affecting
Mass uh length and uh time okay and
let's look at Mass uh this is what
they're saying because they're saying
the effect is real okay it's not
it's not an optical illusion okay
they're saying it's a real effect okay
and here it is okay I'm going to
illustrate it here what they're saying
is that an object that travels close to
the speed of light think of that as
traveling close to the speed of light
expands
okay
and so the question is what happened
there did more atoms did that object
that ball acquired more atoms is that
what happened to that object
and if so by what mechanism I mean how
does speed explain that the object there
this ball acquires more mass mass being
the quantity of matter okay
so that's that's the first problem that
anyone would have to answer but now
let's superimpose on this the fact that
there's going to be as well a
um a flattening out of the object in the
direction of travel something called uh
length contraction let's put them
together and this is what it looks like
okay you can see not only is it gaining
in Mass but it's also you know
flattening out in the direction of
travel
and the question is again by what
mechanism is this happening uh how is it
that requires more mass and at the same
time flattens out
if this is not an optical illusion if
this is uh real you know
so these are the questions that these
folks need to answer and of course they
don't do physics they just want to do
math they just say look we put the
learns factor in there and that's what
we get
yeah great and then they say are we
measured and we obviously proved it
okay so here we have
um
uh the Internet Encyclopedia philosophy
on it these people don't know nobody
else knows they say this effect is real
okay it says objects and processes are
said to look shorter or longer when
viewed in one inertial frame rather than
in another okay that means it's
subjective if it looks to you different
we don't care because that means you
just had more beers to drink okay we or
maybe you shot up who knows it is common
to regard this effect as a purely
conventional choice of reference frame
but this is rather misleading because
time and space dilation are very real
physical effects
okay this is what these people are
saying it's a peer-reviewed uh academic
resource right there is no answer within
special relativity as to which Rod
really gets shorter we could consider
these effects as a matter of perspective
although it is more accurate to say that
in special relativity in its usual
interpretation there are simply no facts
about absolute length or absolute time
or absolute simultaneously
okay at all however this doesn't mean
that time and space dilation are not
real effects
so they keep chasing their tail around
they don't explain it but they say oh
they're for real we've proven it
okay how can you prove that for example
mass increases
I mean what are you saying that it
acquired more atoms is that what you're
saying
and then they say Well when it comes
back to rest you know to your frame of
reference where you're going to take the
measurement it went back to normal
so how do how do you prove you know to
anyone to God you know that this thing
became bigger because it required more
mass more atoms just by just by
traveling at the speed of light in fact
that would seem like they're talking
about weight and not about mass mass is
the quantity of matter weight is the
effect of say the Earth on an object you
know how close or far away you are from
an object uh as far as mathematics is
concerned right and so the the issue
here is this thing is uh going closer to
the speed of light means you got to look
at is it if it approaches something and
now like a scale and it's going to press
on the scale because it's driving close
to the speed of light that's called
weight
it's pressing down on a scale very
strongly because it's struggling close
to the speed of light
if on the other hand uh you know go slow
or is in your frame of reference well
then it weighs whatever it weighs
it goes back to suddenly it lost all
those pounds
you know just stop moving at the speed
of light and you'll lose a lot of weight
you know a bunch of nonsense okay so
these are the questions that I have for
all these special relativists right Mass
quantity of matter or measure of
quantity of matter right if mass is
increased the object acquired more atoms
okay that's that's what they're saying
okay by what physical process that the
object acquire these extra atoms that's
all you have to answer just tell me the
physical process this is physics right
so we don't care about your math we
don't care about the calculations we
don't care about any experiments you did
we just want to know the explanation we
want to understand the explanation thus
by what mechanism the object acquired
more atoms which is what mass is if
they're going to talk about an increase
in mass in other words they're just
saying that
it weighs more because it's pushing down
a close to the speed of light rather
than at a slow pace so they're it's
pushing on the scale at close to the
speed of light it's like if you jump on
the scale well of course you're going to
weigh a little more than you're just
stand there and that's the the
difference that they're talking about
here Motion versus standing still
okay so if they're not talking about
weight they're really talking about Mass
they're talking about acquiring more
atoms please tell us the mechanism
length what is length continuous matter
lying between two surfaces that's what
length is okay we don't measure length
we Define length so that we don't have
to measure okay we don't we don't know
uh how long something is we don't care
we want to know if it is long and for
that we need a definition the definition
is you take a table you treat it as if
it were made of a single piece and you
look at surface to surface that's called
the length of that table it's a
qualitative concept it's the one we use
in physics we have no use for the
quantitative measurement uh notion that
they have in math
uh if the object is shrunk it either
lost atoms or the atoms came closer
together right so if it shrinks what
happened uh the atoms just came closer
together for whatever reason or you chop
some or they lost some or whatever and
that's why it also became uh shorter
right those are I think the only two
possibilities maybe I missed one okay so
and again so by what physical process
did the object do either that's what you
got to answer
how come it came it became shorter okay
and again we don't care about the mass
we don't care about experiments that's
not what we're asking we're asking for a
physical interpretation
time validation what is that an observer
measures a moving clock as ticking
slower than a clock that is at rest in
his reference rate
okay what does that have to do with
physics it just says that we have a
subjective reading because the object
whatever it is you know in this case
could be a clock or whatever it takes at
a certain rate
it doesn't matter what you measure over
here what what another guy measures over
there depending on your frames of
reference we don't care about that we
want to know what the clock itself reads
hopefully the clock it only has one
reading and I'll give you a good clock
uh the earth going around the Sun
it takes one year
one year is defined as one revolution of
the Earth around the Sun
so if one uh twin right we have two
twins one travels at the speed of light
to the galaxies to a black hole and then
comes back
and he says he's uh younger than his
brother because time went slower for him
that he well his brother is 50 or 60
years old he's only 20.
well let's count the number of times the
Earth went around the Sun and we'll find
out who's right
and hopefully the Earth went around the
Sun 20 times or 40 times or 50 times it
can't be both
so we have to use the definition what is
a year year is one revolution of the
Earth around the Sun and whether the guy
comes out there measures with his atomic
clock and comes back and stands on his
head we don't care we want to count the
number of Revolutions of the Earth
around the Sun period that's all we have
to look at okay and so the way that you
got around this is by talking about
proper Mass proper length and proper
time
what is that well proper means uh
uh what they measure
in their local frame of reference in
other words the thing traveling with you
so when you look at time it's the watch
that's traveling with you when you look
at length it's the table or the ruler or
whatever that's traveling with you and
when you look at Mass you're looking at
the object that is going to increase in
Mass but now you're not going to look at
it as increasing Mass because you get it
right there in front of you and so
that's the proper mass and so what
they're saying is that the proper mass
is not the one that expands that
increases the uh proper length is not
the one that flattens out that shortens
right in the direction of travel
and so on and so the question is uh
they're saying that the proper one
doesn't change
meaning that there is no change that
it's only a measurement issue and this
measurement issue has to do with them
someone traveling at the speed of light
in general that's or close to the speed
of light and so we're talking about
measurement we're not talking about
physics here we're talking about the
object did not change
whether it travels at the speed of light
uh it did not flatten out it did not
gain more mass it always remained the
same it's the measurement that they're
talking about they're saying oh we
measured more mass oh we measured that
it's its length uh shrunk in the
direction of trap that's what they're
telling you
but that's just a measurement that's
just you know you can drink four five
beers and reach the same conclusion if
the object itself has not changed if it
its frame of reference it it does not
change at all that's an objective
Criterion the measurement that's not an
objective criteria and that's subjective
because you know you could be uh
influenced by the way the light uh
Shines on your eyes how much strength
you have how many drinks you had you
know it's got nothing to do with what
the object itself did the object itself
did not change they're telling you in
its rainbow reference the ruler remains
12 inches didn't shrink at all and it
did not gain any weight and so what have
they discovered nothing they're just
talking about measurement okay of what
they perceive
and here's a time dilation okay I've
already proven
this proof evidence
okay that uh Einstein's theory is wrong
why because he says that if you take uh
an atomic clock at the top of the Eiffel
Tower there it's going to take
um uh faster than the one at the close
to the Earth because according to him
you know the Earth the gravity you know
whatever gravity is is going to affect
that clock in such a way that it's going
to go slower it's going to tick slower
but you know if you do it with an
hourglass uh you arrive at the opposite
conclusion you know in fact the clock on
the bottom the one closer to the Center
of the Earth that's when it's going to
go faster because it's a gravitational
clock in fact that's the best clock to
test any theory that involves gravity
and time you know so here you have uh
you know an hourglass sand clock right
and it's ticking faster closer to the
Center of the Earth than the clock
that's far out on top of you know the
Eiffel Tower and that destroys the
principle of Relativity okay which they
take as a law of the universe or
something
okay and again the other one is the
earth going around the Sun that's one
year
I don't care how fast the twin went out
there and came back we don't care about
that we just want to know that when he
comes back hopefully the Earth went
around the Sun 20 times or 40 times or a
hundred times but not 20 times for one
guy and 50 for another that doesn't
happen uh that only in relativity does
that happen okay so how do we get around
all these how do we tackle these things
well we use my famous tool the universal
movie okay here it is what is this tool
well it's uh we look at the universe as
single frames as if God takes a snapshot
frame by frame okay of every uh location
that every atom in the universe every
object in the universe has with respect
to all others and for a given snapshot
you know when you take a snapshot
there's nothing moving in a snapshot
well that's going to be a frame the next
frame is the next snapshot the next
frame is the next snapshot and so on
down the line so between these there's
very little motion because as soon as
everything moves one gazillionth of a
billionth of uh this is a gazillionth of
an inch it's already a different frame
okay so uh why do we do this well we try
to make sure that we understand the
static Concepts and separate them from
the Dynamic Concepts all Dynamic
Concepts require at least two frames of
the movie okay so static concept one
frame Dynamic Concepts require at least
two because you're talking about motion
motion is what two locations are more of
an object two frames of the universal
movie all the others the one on the
yellow ones on the top uh object
distance location in existence they do
not require two frames of the movie okay
so this is a useful tool to separate
static from Dynamic Concepts a lot of
people have a lot of problems with this
because they don't understand
uh yeah the stories are religion that's
what it really does so they uh somehow
tend to not understand whatever destroys
their religion that's that's all it's
about okay so what do we put some of
these Concepts from special relativity
well here you have weight mass and
length they are static Concepts okay we
don't need uh more than one frame of the
movie to conceptualize weight mass or
length what is mass the number of atoms
an object has okay does it change from
frame to frame yeah maybe it does we
don't care because that's not what we're
asking we're saying those mass in a
single frame of the movie does an object
have the same number of atoms there or
does it change in that single frame and
the answer is no if a ball has one
trillion atoms
in that single frame that's the mass of
that object one trillion atoms so mass
is a static concept similarly the lathe
is the separation you know from one
surface to the other side of a surface
of an object okay we treat as if it were
made of a single piece table could be
for example and so that's called the
length of the table we don't care how
much it measures it has no meaning in
physics okay we just care to know what
the word length means okay we don't roll
the measuring tape from one Edge to the
other in science what we do is we Define
the word length and weight again is the
number of uh
electromagnetic ropes
the individual right uh
electromagnetic ropes that bind any two
objects so again the number of ropes is
a given number in any frame of the movie
that's what weight is you have weight
for uh it's location specific you have
weight only for a given location
with respect to the Earth you change
your location you have a different
weight okay so difference in weight
that's two frames we're not talking
about difference in weight we're talking
about weight and that has to be a
certain number of ropes at a given
distance distance being a static concept
okay where do we put all the others this
word increase contraction those are
Dynamic Concepts volume and other
Dynamic concept and speed okay so all
these are Dynamic Concepts that require
more than one frame of the movie so once
we separate these we can now begin to
talk a little more intelligently about
the conclusions reached by a special
relativity uh especially with respect to
weight Mass length and whether any of
these change okay
and the question and the issue is no
they don't change because again they're
even telling you that the proper length
and the proper Mass do not change
meaning the mass
uh that is traveling with you so to
speak you know the one in your frame of
reference so if that doesn't change
uh then they haven't discovered anything
what they're saying is the guy far away
and the other planet that's watching you
he measures and he measures something
different than what you're measuring
there okay we don't care the real value
is the one that you're traveling with
that's the important one because that's
what it is that's objective what the
other guy measures is because he's
traveling fast or he didn't see it very
well he doesn't have a proper tools or
he drank too much we don't care
what we care about is the objective the
proper length the proper mass is the
correct value it's an objective value so
don't tell me that the thing increased
in Mass when it didn't you're just
saying that you measured it to have
increased meaning you measure the weight
because you don't measure mass masses
you count you count the number of atoms
of an object
weight you measure and what they're
doing is measuring weight how much a an
object that travels close to the speed
of light presses down on the scale and
they call that Mass
that's where their error is it's not my
answer talking about weight okay
and as far as length contraction well
yeah anything can contract but again
they're saying that the proper length
does not contract and the proper time
does not change either the one that you
have in your watch when you're traveling
right that one stays with you that
doesn't change what's changing is what
the other guy is measuring with his
clock about your your motion who cares
that that doesn't affect my watch my
watch is still you know measuring what
it should be measuring
so if another person measures something
different you know we don't care and
again the way we settle these things is
we come back to earth and we say how
many times did the earth go around the
Sun
and then you can divide that by Days by
hours by minutes by second then you'll
know how many seconds really when uh you
know around uh you know which clock is
correct the one that matches the number
of seconds that the Earth uh had for 20
revolutions that's when it gets the
cigar that's how simple it is
so it's all very simple uh in physics
it's all objective there's no
subjectivity we don't use observers we
don't take measurements we don't do
calculations we don't care about any of
that in physics okay in science math is
a language only it is and that's that's
why it has nothing to do with physics
you can never merge the language of
physics with the science of physics
never that means you'll mean okay so uh
what do we say in the end we say Mass
quantity of matter that's what it is
okay uh in other words proper Mass
that's what we care about weight number
of independent rows uh that
um between two objects that bind two
objects okay independent uh or what we
call effective ropes two objects a
standing still at a given distance from
each other snapshot right how many ropes
are there if they're connecting them
that's the uh that's the mass okay and
then continuous manner between you know
two surfaces okay so you have surface of
the table you treat it as an object made
of a single piece table is not made of
parts we don't talk about muriology in
physics okay that's a religion known as
mariology what something is made out of
okay we don't care about that we look at
a table we say it's made out of a single
piece we look at one Edge to the other
and that's the length
do we unroll the measuring tape to find
out how how long it is no we don't
because length here on Earth is the same
as length the definition of length right
as in the land of the Klingons length is
length as length is length always should
be the same okay I don't care if you're
in the land of the Klingons surface to
surface
is the if they have a different uh
measuring tape you know different uh
units uh what should we do commit
suicide and say oh but they don't have
inches and they don't have feet and they
don't have meters what what should I do
now
they have the x's and the Y's yeah
that's why it doesn't matter length we
have to Define not measure
and then the other two Notions there we
don't care about because they don't
belong to physics okay they're stuff
that belongs exclusively to mathematics
we don't have use for time in physics we
have no use for volume why because in
science we have to explain a mechanism
that's what physics is about explaining
a physical mechanism time plays no role
in an explanation and bond doesn't
either as far as I can tell I mean I
don't know maybe someone will find some
way of putting volume in there I doubt
it uh with this time relation between
two motions okay you have to have memory
there to memorize the original points
and then compare them against their
ending points and this fellow says what
if they're cheating on you irrelevant uh
we're talking about the definition but
he doesn't understand that okay and then
we have volume displaced
um encapsulating medium so if you have
an encapsulating medium such as water
right or air and you're going to put the
fish or the bird in the air or the fish
in the water how much water does it
displace that's called volume okay so
it's a dynamic concept
again we have no use for volume in
science okay
and uh with that I guess uh we
uh clean our nose holes with all of
Relativity special relativity right
um it has no no uh validity in science
and it has nothing to do with physics at
all what these people are talking about
is measuring and subjectivity that's
what they're talking about physics is
objective there are no observers in
physics no measurement no equations
we don't use words such as time it's a
four-letter word okay
literally okay it you know we don't use
those words we have no use for time in
physics and mass uh number of atoms uh I
don't know if that has any validity in
physics maybe maybe you could you know
have some use for it uh
uh the only way I use it is to say that
um the atom the hydrogen atom is the
unit of mass okay that's one way that I
use it uh the more hydrogen atoms uh the
more the bigger the element is uranium
has 92 hydrogen atoms essentially so in
that sense I use Mass uh weight
the only way I use it is just to explain
that weight is a static concept it's
location specific you move an inch
farther away from the earth or closer to
the Earth you have a different weight so
weight is location specific location is
a static concept what are we talking
about we're talking about the number of
ropes that interconnect every atom of
one object to every atom of the other
object that's essentially the main point
obviously each one of the objects is
also bound to every other atom in the
universe by electromagnetic ropes as
well in those inter intervene as well in
in this tug of war okay so all that's
got to be factored in to the notion of
weight
okay uh and that's different than the
acceleration of gravity by the way
acceleration of gravity when you have
many weights wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait and as you get closer the
ropes fan out you have more independent
ropes more effective ropes and therefore
weight changes as you approach the Earth
that acceleration of gravity uh is uh
many weights
many measurements of Weights okay
okay let's move on to our uh
science critic and he talked a little
bit about
um
prediction you made a video about
prediction and like I said the other day
in fact I've been talking about that the
last couple times he never understood
and he still doesn't understand the
difference between an explanation and a
description and until he does he's just
spinning his wheels he thinks that a
explanation is just a description and
vice versa and what is a synonym of
another they're not okay explanation is
not a description the scripture is not
an explanation and all predictions are
just descriptions they are not
explanations if you can explain why
something is going to happen now you're
talking about the past and not about the
future prediction okay so here it is let
me put them on and I think the sound is
a little high so you may want to turn
your volume a little low I don't I don't
know that for a fact but I think it was
a little bit High okay just in case I'm
wanting you so
um let me turn this on give me a second
here here it goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
a prediction is just a description
a description is not a theory
a description is not an explanation
either
let's take this example someone says
we're Nick's going to see Haley's Comet
in 2061. now how are they working that
out well the worked out that we see how
he's coming every 75 to 76 years and the
last time that we saw it was in 1986 so
the next time that we'll see it will be
in 2061. now that is an explanation for
why you can always ask okay why do we
see it every 75 years and the answer to
that is well it circles the Sun and you
can ask why does it Circle the Sun Well
it circle's the Sun but source of
gravity but if someone says that in two
years it's going to go through a
wormhole so we'll end up seeing it in
five years then that is a prediction
that can be tested if that doesn't end
up happening then we know that that
explanation that they gave is false
okay so what is the problem the problem
is again he doesn't understand the
difference between an explanation and a
description no mathematician ever does
okay that's why they confused math with
science because science is about
explaining
and Mathematics never explains anything
has no power no authority to explain all
it can do is describe and predictions
are descriptions
and so they get this issue where they
say we can predict oh that means you
know and science is about knowledge so
uh predictions are part of science
that's more or less how they figure this
out and turns out that no science is
about explanation so it doesn't have
anything to do with knowledge or with
predictions okay in science we do not
know in science we do not predict in
science we have to explain a mechanism
as it relates to physics okay so here uh
we have the situation yeah the
step-by-step circles the sun that's uh
not a cause or an explanation okay the
fact that circles the sun you still have
it you just you that's another
description you're saying it circles the
Sun
but you haven't answered the question is
what causes and by saying circle is the
sun you haven't answered the cause the
mechanism
because of gravity again uh you haven't
explained the cause gravity is not a
cause gravity is a description you're
saying well every time I let go of the
pen so it falls to the ground why
because of gravity
well so far you just put another word in
it you just describe you haven't given
me a mechanism okay gravity is not a
mechanism gravity is just a word that's
used to describe the effect that you
still don't understand okay so let's
separate descriptions from an
explanation
uh we'll return in five years you know
the comment right that's a description
so uh in other words you just made a
prediction you say it will return in
five years okay whether it does or not
is irrelevant okay because all you did
so far is describe a prediction is just
that a description but then he says
swallowed by a wormhole or whatever it
doesn't matter now you've given an
explanation you said that this is the
cause the cause it will come back in
five years or two years or whatever is
because it went through a wormhole
okay and now you're giving a mechanism
say look we'll assuming everybody
understands what a wormhole is okay it
goes through this whole and somehow
there's an effect there that causes
the comment to appear earlier or later
or whatever okay so you're explaining
why the comet is not going to appear in
75 years but in five years in two years
or whatever fine no problem and you're
saying it's because it goes through a
wormhole the Wormhole does something as
long as you can explain that something
because again the Wormhole is up there
and again Wormhole is an irrational uh
explanation why because wormholes uh you
know is an equation
uh and equations don't swallow you know
comets but you're treating uh the
Wormhole assuming you know you you make
the assumption that Wormhole is a
physical thing then you could say well
it does something to the comet slows it
down it speeds it up you can do all that
kind of stuff only if the uh Wormhole is
a physical object otherwise it's an
irrational explanation and here let me
show you what a wormhole looks like okay
you always wanted to know what a
wormhole looks like here it is okay I'm
the first guy to show this on planet
Earth okay so get your cameras ready
here it goes this is what a wormhole
looks like
okay
and this comes out of the Wikipedia says
an example of a traversable wormhole
metric is the following it shows a bunch
of letters that with pluses signs and
negative signs in front of them and what
is all this well this looks like an
equation to me one type of non-trump
traversable Wormhole metric is the
schwarzilla solution and there you have
another equation then the original
Einstein Rosen Bridge which is what a
wormhole is technically called was
described described oh not explained
okay was described in an article
published in 1935 for the source showed
uh spherically symmetric stage static
solution there we have it okay so what a
wormhole looks like is an equation
that's what it is it's an Iceland Rose
Einstein Rosen Bridge it's an equation
that's all it ever was okay so this
notion that people have oh it's a it's a
hole that goes from our universe to
another universe or whatever you enter
here through the black hole you come out
the other side to a white hole or
whatever oh that answer it's an equation
that's all it is okay Wormhole equation
Einstein rosenbridge okay so you can't
say that so in that sense it an
irrational explanation because they're
saying okay the Wormhole is going to
speed up the the comment okay fine how
did it do that well you say well
Wormhole has these properties and that's
why it did it okay now you're giving an
explanation but the problem is that the
Wormhole is an equation and you can't
use that to explain a physical mechanism
so even his example was wrong he could
have used some something else but
um explanation is past tense yeah you
you explained a consummated event ex and
so even if you say look
uh Y is what's going to happen to the
comment it's going to come in five years
so far you only did a description now
someone says why is it going to come in
five years okay and the guy says it's
going to come in five years because of a
wormhole okay it does something to it
whatever
well it only works in Reverse
explanations only work in Reverse okay
and the way it works is once it happened
once it comes back in five years you can
say this is the cause this is what
caused
the uh comments had come back in five
years instead of 75 years now you can
explain retroactively what happened you
say it went through a wormhole that
speeded it up
only can only then can use it like that
but if you say it in advance that it's
going to go through a wormhole well how
did you know it's going to go through a
wormhole now
okay that's the issue okay and that's
going to be a little tough to answer
okay
uh again explanations only in retrospect
not not in advance in advance it's only
prediction if you can explain it you
either had the experience with it it
happened once which in this case never
happened so you can't use that as an
experience and for that you can only
wait until the event happens to talk
about it in retrospect and say now I can
explain why the Haley's comment you know
came uh in five years instead of 75
years later
okay so that's the way it works in
science
okay folks uh yeah no I'm not gonna
answer any more questions there because
uh essentially I've answered uh most of
the important ones uh with the issue of
space-time and so we'll see you again
next week we're going to continue in
this line of questioning line of uh
lecturing